this week conflict zone is in the West
Bank city of Ramallah and my guest is
the Prime Minister Rami hamdallah the
peace process with Israel is in deep
freeze and with almost daily stabbings
of Israelis by Palestinians it's hard to
see how it can be restarted so is this
troubled land slipping once again into
war
Prime Minister welcome to conflict zone
thank you your government has failed to
make any moves towards a peace process
with Israel failed to effectively unify
with Hamas does your government deserve
to survive actually we have to start
with the peace track the peace track and
Palestine is dealt with by the PLO and
we as a government we had ducked always
the program the PLO but collectively you
have failed to make any inroads any
progress on the peace actually you have
to look for the embed Amanda which is
actually your Israel actually we have
been occupied for almost 15 years we are
seeking freedom and justice we are
adopting nonviolent resistance and we
asked Israel to apply all UN resolutions
and you are hopeless it is United at the
same time let me finish you we hope that
Israel apply first of all all you are
resolutions which call on Israel that
will draw from our land and to establish
our Palestinian independent sovereign
state but look what those rates are
doing a daily basis you know with the
two states vision actually we talked
about independent variable Palestinian
state over the 67 borders with East
Jerusalem as our capital but the
expansion of settlements on daily basis
prime minister kills actually it kills
the viability of a Palestinian I
understand Prime Minister how are the
Israelis supposed to make peace with the
Palestinians when the Palestinians are
so disunited if they make peace with
Fatah they're not going to be able to
have peace with Hamas that's fine in
theory but it doesn't work in practice
because as you well know actually this
is out of context you know in 1994 it
was the PLO which reached the agreement
with Israel if you remember Oslo Accords
it was signed between you Italy
disunited actually as a Palestinian
movement you are fatally disunite but at
this time actually actually nothing who
has been using this structure as a means
for not reaching I get an agreement
believes right isn't it before 2007
disunity four before 2007 weren't we
when I United we were United
actually but now we are doing or by
statute to reach a unity government
Hamas is invited you've been doing your
best for a long time but it doesn't get
it does it you've been trying to unify
for years we have we have not doesn't
work we should not lose hope we keep it
rolling and now there are serious talks
actual between Fatah and Hamas to unite
are serious talks for years Prime
Minister let's hope you know for the
last 10 years you've been having serious
talks and they get nowhere why why can
you not in the interests of the
Palestinian people put aside your
differences you know my government is
called a consensus government we are
trying our best to unite we are doing
it's in name only consensus in name only
not in fact look at the reconstruction
are shown in Gaza who is doing the
reconstruction now it says the
government is my government so far how
much reconstruction is going on in Gaza
very little very little compared to what
is needed you need the statistics or you
need wheels Oh bad we have repaired 98
thousand rolls which we are partially
demolished by the Israelis we have
started with five thousand units which
we are fully demolished and remind you
you know we had the reconstruction
conference in Cairo and the bridges were
around the five billion dollars only 28%
over the bridges actually we're
fulfilled Prime Minister your opinion
polls by Palestinian organizations show
a population that is moving towards
support of an armed Intifada growing
numbers of people again can you stop
that or is that where the situation is
headed
I talk to the Israelis about look
they're doing I'm talking to you about
what you do look up others are doing you
know you asked about the individuals
okay about the people when you look at
your the daily killings the
extrajudicial killings which happening
on daily basis if you look at demolition
reforms what about the ballast
for stabbing Israelis on a daily basis
if we're talking about daily killings if
you if you see the transfer of people
from certain places to another which is
actually you know in contradiction with
international law
look at all these activities which are
done by the Israelis on daily basis
actually you have entire generation of
Palestinians who live the whole of their
lives
this was this wasn't the question we are
we are I understand but this wasn't the
question
and I was asking we are this is but you
are weak well if you are a weak
government in the in the opinion polls
that were carried out January this year
by the Arab world for research and
development 33 percent said you are weak
this is the predominant feeling about
you and your government weakness so you
can't stop the slide towards an Intifada
can you continue actually our path is
peaceful means Israel has to abide by
the international law this is the only
viable we actually do it for Israel to
apply I'm asking what you might do and
you keep turning it round to Israel I
ask you Israelis what the Israelis are
doing I'm asking you what you were doing
this how can you stop this slide towards
the Intifada let's talk about facts we
need a political poison this is the fact
that you need a political you need the
political horizon you have to give our
people hope actually we have been under
occupation for 51 years and you must
give them hope you slide them towards
Intifada this is the way they are going
there should be Israel as we all the
time talking about economic developments
here and there but this is we don't need
this actually what we need we need the
political horizon which gives hope or
children when I talk about entire
generation who have lived their lives
under occupation 60% of the people have
not lived Gaza actually they are not
lived Gaza for a while
imagine what would you call the disease
on Gaza the closure in Gaza which has
been for almost eight years now let's
talk about the political horizon within
the Palestinian territory
as things stand you have a president who
is 11 years into what is supposed to be
a five-year term the lack of effective
oversight on the president has meant
years of shady dealing at the heart of
government hasn't it no reforms nepotism
corruption has been rampant in the
Palestinian Authority hasn't it that's
the political horizon that you offer
your people here it's not great is it
this is actually not the truth actually
this is completely unfair something
comes from Palestinian Palestinian
sources Palestinian - I actually at
Palestine we created institutions
actually based on transparency and
accountability not voting to the
chairman of the accountability and
integrity coalition we have the public
audit Bureau we have anti-corruption
committee but as in any country actually
in any institution you find people
actually who have certain misconduct and
these people actually are freed up by
our committees and prime minister abdul
khader al hussein is the chairman of the
coalition for accountability and
integrity he said that with without a
reactivation of the Legislative Council
which you don't have said without it
your much-heralded
anti-corruption Drive will continue to
limp absolute power he said means
absolute corruption and that's what you
have absolute power and absolute
corruption so he's lying is he Abdel
Fattah al hussein is like actually what
we are saying actually that we have
bodies that follow up any charges
against anyone and we investigate and
actually we are product to develop
transparency and accountability
look at this bills what is he saying
actually Finn and I overcome - maybe he
cannot make these statements less than a
year ago the Palestinian Coalition for
accountability and integrity flagged up
its own concerns it said failure to
adopt a national comprehensive and
participatory plan against corruption
concerns that the Ministry of Finance
has ceased to disseminate budgets and
data an ongoing rise in official
salaries in state institutions a
declining number of reports being
published by the state audit and
Ministry of Control Bureau and you talk
about transparency and anti-corruption
Drive I talk and look look it's at odds
with the facts look at the report which
has which have been given by your
independent bodies but look at the
reports which have recently published by
that you for instance by IMF by the
World Bank I don't know why real
sightings just so what you wanted let's
talk about the you talk about the EU
because for green only just only
yesterday there was a statement by that
you saying how transparent or mister
finances well I don't know who was
speaking but but let me tell you but
federica mogherini gave you 250 million
euros at the start of this month
she said Palestinian institutions must
become more transparent more accountable
and more democratic viable and inclusive
institutions based on respect for the
rule of law and human rights are crucial
in the establishment of an independent
and sovereign Palestinian state so she
felt the need on 1st of March a few days
ago to remind you that accountability
transparency and honesty are essential
we are a counter that's not exactly a
ringing endorsement of your government
we are in countable we are transparent
and the money you just mentioned it is
the contribution of they you for a whole
year actually yes some of it will go to
our salaries some of it will go to other
projects and this is audited all that
monthly basis why they why she sang
Palestinian institutions must become
more transparent more accountable and
more democratic I work I wanted you to
look at the report which was published
only yesterday in Tabriz by the EU which
talks about how transparent and how
accountable we are but here I think miss
Morgan is saying about the new pledge
which is around 250 to millions which is
a which is supposed to be dispersed in
2016 some of it will go towards salaries
some of it will go towards projects but
we are committed we are all born as me
sure happy senior official of your
accountability watchdog that there are
big black holes in the Palestinian
financial and administrative system that
need to be addressed he
various public departments have become
private kingdoms big black holes and
private Kingdom actually that's what
your independent watchdogs are telling
naturally and you say it's nonsense
actually this is not affect this is not
affect well how is he got it so well
this is another thing you have to look
into other reports you have to look into
all the reports like vampire corruption
committee which is run by independent
body in Palestine and to see how
transparent the other reports show that
two attempts last August
created a huge stir here to tell us by
Palestinian officials to misuse funds
one was a request signed by a diplomatic
adviser to the president who asked
Bahrain's foreign minister for four
million dollars to fund the private
housing complex here and another showed
a senior official from the borders
authority trying to get you to pay
fifteen thousand dollars for his
family's health and educational expenses
this is the kind of corruption this is
proved to be false actually somebody
wrote a letter asking for fifteen
thousand yes but nobody has paid him
actually but anyone in a democratic
nation can write to the Prime Minister
on can write to the prison requesting
certain thing but that doesn't mean that
we will respond to his letter and this
what happened actually but people can
write whatever they want they can
request what all they want people have
legitimate demands here like your
teachers for instance public schools
have been on strike for a month and yet
you crack down on teachers you're the
one who said the Palestinian teacher
deserves our respect and admiration but
you meet them with riot police threats
of arrest threats of being sacked again
overnight detention this is how you show
your admiration I myself am a teacher
originally I became from a teacher
background the president is a teacher we
highly respect our teachers and our
industry you meet them with riot police
when they have legitimate tinman
III finish please actually we are
investing in human resources and we
value the work for teachers I wish you
were here last Tuesday when thousands of
teachers demonstrated here in the front
of my office and nobody intervened with
one of their comments last month a
secondary school teacher from Bethlehem
attended a protest demonstration she
told one of your newspapers
we passed four checkpoints policemen
intelligence army and they asked if we
were teachers or not and we had to lie
just to pass but as if we were criminals
she said as if we were criminals I can't
confirm that thousands of people arrived
in the front of my office this would not
happen in too many countries actually
they came in to here they protested that
they stood for hours even they closed
whole street and no army intervened and
even you know I tell you an example at
you what happened there last Tuesday
teachers distributed flowers to the
security who were guarding the
demonstration where this will happen and
this is a fact I saw it myself
your action was denounced by the
Palestinian Center for Human Rights
it was denounced the security measures
that you took the attempts to stop
teachers reaching the demonstrations
temp to stop them coming into Rome but
why why but when they came anyway but
they came after this and these are the
largest demonstrations in the West Bank
420 this is you know the 20th the fact
is that thousands of them arrived here
they said what they wanted and it is
actually though the strike actually is
not legal because it had to go through
certain procedures actually even though
we accepted that we respected their
being here and I think you know
resources or the most valuable issue for
and none of them are going to be sacked
for taking part in demonstrations none
of them none of them has been even
detailed yes they have 22 were detained
of and one of them I can't confirm one
of them has been detained they were so
the reports are awful they were did
detainees three weeks ago when there was
incitement and they were released the
second day there were 16 of them
released immediately after one night I
can confirm this why do you crackdown on
free speech hear you say you allow
demonstrators to demonstrate you say
that give me an example well last year
for example last year Freedom House
reported that several media outlets are
teeny pressured to provide favorable
coverage of the PA and fatah journalists
who criticize the PA or Fatah faced
arbitrary arrest threats and physical
abuse according to Freedom House you
don't recognize this mistakes can happen
anywhere they can happen in Germany they
can happen in here but if anyone's a bit
more than mistakes this sounds like a
policy doesn't it the Palestinian Centre
for development and media freedoms
reported last year 38 press freedom
violations by Palestinian forces in the
West Bank in the first half of 25 is
this is not all policy I have to but it
happens doesn't it everywhere actually
and usually we envision every one we're
talking about what happens here usually
we investigate any incident actually
that happens actually and we can't bring
anyone to trial actually if you commit
mistakes in the West Bank 37 arrests and
24 summonses were based on Facebook
protests comments even so-called people
putting a like on to the Facebook page
and these were perceived to be critical
of the PA so there were 37 arrests and
24 summonses I can't tell you actually
and this is a fact we are proud of the
democracy we practice in Palestine
people can't see anything can't
criticize me correctly so Freedom House
is around all your critic look look look
at the newspapers look at the websites
actually I wish you could just go
through certain Palestine websites and
see what the people are writing and what
I'm saying we never can try anyone for
what he says or what he speaks actually
and there's no torture in the West Bank
I cannot deny that sometimes the you
know certain incidents happen and this
is the fact that we investigate these
and anyone really who was try anyone who
is charged with the torture actually
will be throw it Travis the Amnesty
International in its latest report for
2015 2016 says torture and other ill
treatment of detainees remained common
and was committed with impunity by
Palestinian police and other security
forces in the West Bank actually this is
this is not the policy but it's how does
it happen
I tell you this heavens an individual
basis sometimes mistakes have been
promised
I've been asking questions in in
Palestine about torture in your
detention facilities for the last 25
years and every time I ask these
questions somebody says we're working on
it and it's a few more cases and this
kind of but it doesn't change does it
you said you said before we started the
interview that nothing changes here this
doesn't change doesn't nothing it
changes with regard to the Israeli
occupation nothing changes with regard
to what we're up ssin and torture we are
proud of the democracy we have we are
what actually this is why we keep seeing
investment in Palestine investment in
peace is investment in democracy and
stability look at Palestine Palestine is
a model for tolerance for coexistence
look at Muslims Christians Americans
live as one family why you look at the
you know the certain mal forms
incidents that happen here and there
things can happen anywhere I don't deny
that certain things have an actual
torture happens but this is not a policy
once we discover then you're not
bringing to account those who carry out
choice how many people have you actually
only lovely last year only right eight
persons will try that's it right I'm the
Minister of Interior also in my capacity
actually eight people were tried and
sacked from the service actually I kill
you for torture some of them yes but
when you talk about eight persons it's
not that huge number actually it's not
it's not that you example we are against
it but if you look at no 8 persons
Israel's main problem with you is
incitement isn't it Israel's Deputy
Foreign Minister Tzipi hatov Lee spoke
in January of a direct relationship
between the Palestinian who stabbed a 39
year old mother to death in front of her
children in January and incitement from
the Palestinian media why do you allow
incitement in your media but why don't
you talk about the alien so you know why
I'm talking about what they do but it's
not an answer to the question let me
explain again we are committed to
nonviolent resistance incidents happen
by individuals why do I don't know when
we
television vision we are committed we
always say that the president and myself
will always say that we are committed to
nonviolent resistance this is all part
but you broadcast a music video called
on Palestine on the field around them
the Jews in a sea of blood and kill them
as you wish I tell you why I tell you
you have entire nations who have my name
of them have lived their entire lives
under occupation with these people
suffer collective punishment but these
people see their homes demolished is
that a reason as well site Israel Israel
pushes these people towards is that we
have to see a political horizon we have
to give these people these young
generations we have to give them is that
a reason to allow insight we don't drown
the Jews in the sea of blood and kill
them as you wish this is what's
broadcast on your media we don't allow
incitement this is not really the first
she got it wrong the Deputy Foreign
Minister that I think she always get it
wrong actually once you describe
Palestinians as sneak such a Palestine
children snakes is in this incitement if
you look at the time asking a few there
Israelis about what they do I'm asking
you about what you do i I still you our
commitment is to nonviolent resistance
this is our so why so many stabbings
then by Palestinians taking place on a
daily basis there were reports of two
more let's just but just before we came
in and these things appear they occurred
inside Israel proper and this is not
under our control
Israel really has to look for you don't
condemn them do you Israel you offer you
offer in fact you are understanding you
know we we are we are against right any
violations
anywhere we are your chief negotiator
mr. Erekat sir America describes them as
people who lost hope and were deprived
of their future
he offers understanding for cold-blooded
this is this is why don't you condemn
these stabbings observe already saying
that we are committed to nonviolent
resistance this is you're not saying I
did them these people stabbed is an
innocent
this is our commitment actually we are
against we are against any variant
action anywhere and you condemn we all
who go and kill yourself is Rayleigh
what about you know the 100 listen 186
Palestinians have been killed since
October the 1st and many of them are
children and women only though means the
a mother of five children was killed
actually what do you call this what do
you call it what you call it what you
call it when Palestinians stab innocent
Israelis I'm telling you what do you
call that I am Telling You they won't
answer
people you won't answer here no I'm
answering you I as a government as a
leadership our commitment is to
non-violent resistance this is our
message to our people nonviolent reasons
but not to PE we wanted not to peace
reaching peace yes this what we want you
to reach what is going to unblock the
stalemate what can you do you I know you
put the onus on the Israelis but what
can you the Palestinians do to advance a
peace process
oh if you look in the past how difficult
compromises we made through the host
what course and we are still committed
to reach really historical political
settlement with Israel based the UN
resolutions and be the two states vision
a vision that is losing popularity among
your citizens I think that'll actually
Israel is responsible for that when
people see these daily killings the
demolition of homes
closure on Gaza collected punishments
transfer of people from one place to
another which is like you know this is
in contradiction of the international
challenges your government is the
Palestinian Authority going to collapse
because Israel is making plans but on
the basis that it will come up saying
this is going to come up I think the P
is a strong actually it will not
collapse our people are in line with us
actually
and we are committed to our goals and
this is actually an achievement that
we're not allowed to collapse actually
but we will be doing it actually we
started our institutions and we are
prepared for the state and I wanted to
remind you of a blank report which sees
Palestinian institutions right now are
much better than the institutions in 80
countries which we have found before us
what do you call this
we are ready for the state actually
alright and this is the solution Prime
Minister we have to leave it there thank
you very much time
you